and this advert comes on every Christmas
Day in England is there an old lady near
you cold and lonely this Christmas yep I
[ __ ] hate her
nosy [ __ ] wines me up all year round I
cannot wait for the cold weather I'll
tell you
there's no old lady she um she died of
hypothermia so it was all um the other
big campaign is a dog is for life not
just for Christmas
um and that I'm right behind animal
welfare and that's obviously aimed at
parents who those kids go can I have a
puppy can have a puppy no can I have a
puppy and I give in to shut them up but
they like the puppy when it's cute then
they get bored when they grow out of it
and they Lumber the parents with it and
they abandon it 11 000 pets were
abandoned in England last year which is
terrible and I think kids should have
pets I think it teaches them life
lessons I haven't got children of my own
but I've got loads of niece and nephews
and I've got kids of their own now and I
want to be a cool uncle and give them
what they want but I want to be a
responsible one too and not add to the
Stray problem but I think I've solved
the Dilemma this is what I do is a tip
you have to wait till Christmas Eve and
always go to animal shelters not
breathers and I go along to these animal
rescue homes and I go to the veterinary
part and when they're sort of like
putting down euthanizing the sort of
ones the little runts that have got no
quality of life they're too sick I go no
don't kill that one
I'll take that one
and they go it's only going to live a
day
perfect
so I rush home with it I'm going don't
die yet don't die yet put a little bit
of Starbucks don't die yet and I Rush In
And I call my little niece she runs over
to me I go look here puppy yeah your
best uncle got you a puppy I'm gonna go
and play with it quick go and play with
it
and she takes it to bed Christmas Eve
and she plays with it and she sleeps
that she wakes up in the morning cold
dead stiff gone so uh not a problem and
they always come down the next day
because they're going oh my puppy's dead
my puppy's dead I go what the puppy your
uncle got you he did his bit and
whatever happened after that isn't his
problem yeah I go maybe you rolled over
on it and then I oh did I
oh no yeah and I go I killed my puppy I
killed my puppy I don't know you didn't
kill your puppy Jesus killed your puppy
on his birthday
because you didn't spend enough on your
uncle's Christmas present
thanks very much